is supergirl the first is the biggest
show that you've gotten or do you think
um jane the virgin was
that was probably your first biggest
show yeah and that was a popular show i
mean didn't the cast or something get
nominated for a golden globe in that
yeah our first season right so it was
something that people did you ever watch
it ryan no i never thought yeah but a
lot of people did yeah and so that was
your first big break because that's
something that your your mom and your
dad sort of like their eyes open like oh
wait a minute our little girl is is
doing something big now
mom yes dad still wasn't sold she still
wasn't sold still wasn't we're gonna get
there but i think
jane was so unexpected in that uh i came
on episode two right after the pilot and
then by
by our
by episode nine we were at the golden
globes and peabody awards and people's
choice awards so it was it was very uh
jarring in in an exciting way but it
bonded a lot of us i think because we
were like what are we doing in essex
well it had to be exciting going from
what are they called tele novella yeah
was that right telenovela shows soap
operas to surfer girl yeah
you know to
jane the virgin and being at the golden
globes yeah that had to be like an eye
opener for you for for the people around
you're going hey she's because a lot of
times you know we do not great work yeah
or we do great work and something that's
not great yeah it was the first time
people really want like were fans and
watch they paid attention to you yeah
they're like she's something to look at
she's something to to and more of the sh
the show like i think people have a very
intense emotional attachment to it
um i was at this this book store in
vancouver that i go to a lot and the
woman that was working out front like
uh came up and was like i just want you
to know like
this jane the virgin was my pandemic
like my brother passed and she started
crying and it was like very but like
that's really common for that show
because it to feel good and people it's
like their safe place wow so it was the
first time i'd had that where
people were sharing very intimate
information because i was a part of
something that was
special to them how often do people come
up to you and recognize you how often do
you get that
um it depends
in vancouver much more i think just
because we're all there uh people know
in l.a no one gives a because it's
like
actors are everywhere yeah yeah right
yeah and still i think jane is the one
because it feels personal i think it's
like when someone shares something about
themselves that's vulnerable and
someone's experienced that uh then you
want to come up and share that with that
person whether it's your mental health
struggles or um
you know a million things deals with
suicide as a story line then you get
people that come up to you and and want
to share that and so i think with jane
specifically anywhere um whether it's
like immigration story lines they they
want to tell their they want to tell you
their story
you